you have to be super clear about
what kind of company you're trying to
build what your approach is as much as
we want to think that we know
exactly what our mission in life is and
what our chosen profession is going to
be at 22
hell no in my 20s i i didn't get to read
uh much at all want to be happy
build a life not just a business
i believe a life hey it's evancar
michael and this channel was created to
help you overcome the number one
challenge that is holding you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you too
you have michael jordan level genius at
something
so today let's live your best believe
life and learn how billionaires think
and get some success advice from the top
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one don't just follow the trends with
elon musk
don't just follow the trend so um
you may have heard me say that it's good
to think in terms of
the physics approach or first principles
which is
rather than reasoning by analogy you
boil things down to
the most fundamental truths you can
imagine and you reason up from there
and this is a good way to figure out if
if something really makes sense or if
it's just
what everybody else is doing
it's hard to think that way you can't
think think that way about everything
it takes a lot of effort but if you're
trying to do something new
it's the best way to think and that
framework was developed
by by physicists to figure out
counter-intuitive things
like quantum mechanics so it's really a
powerful
powerful method rule number two read
with bill gates
the nice thing now that i'm not
uh so extreme in my 20s i i
didn't get to read uh much at all
and so like all this stuff is going on
in biology and math um
i just didn't didn't get to read it then
when i did get into my 30s
those vacations were a time
to go back uh because when i was a
student
you know you could study all sorts of
things uh
anyway um now
you know i read a lot of science uh and
that
uses up uh you know maybe half of the
slots
uh that that i have
really understanding u.s poverty and
what's going on there there's a
a few dozen books that try and give you
a glimpse of that that are very good
this book facts on this let me say you
know it definitely uh
creates a framing uh for what's going on
in the world
and the other one that's right up there
is any uh
pinker book starting with a
better angels of our nature rule number
three
do what you love with oprah winfrey the
way to make movies is to do stuff that
you love because
you know for 25 years i worked on the
oprah show
and uh steven will tell you that there
were day nights that i came home and i
almost you know it's hard to even like
take off my clothes because i knew i was
going to
be getting up four hours later but i
never really
felt exhausted like deplet never i felt
exhausted but i never felt depleted
so do the work that comes straight from
the soul of you from your background
from stories that you've grown up with
from stories that
bring you passion from stories that you
not just yearn to tell but that if you
don't tell them they won't get told
and when you when you are operating you
know the single
the single greatest uh wisdom
i think i've ever received other than
when people show you they are
is that the key to fulfillment
success happiness contentment
in life is when you align
your personality with what your soul
actually came to do i believe everybody
has a soul and has
you know their own personal spiritual
energy
so when you can use your personality to
serve
whatever that thing is you
can't help but be successful so if you
do films that come from the interior of
your soul
you do work you do art that comes from
the interior of you
it you cannot miss it's only when you're
doing stuff that you think might make
money
you think it may be a hit
or you think it may bring you some level
of attention or success
that isn't what does it i would have to
say that all of the great
wonderful experiences of my life that
have brought me to this moment
have come from working from the interior
of myself
and so that's why it feels so authentic
because it
it actually is so when you do that
you'll win
also if you want to build more
confidence the sign says it can take up
to 254 days
of consecutive action to successfully
build
a habit so i've created a free program
for you where every day
for 254 days i will send you an unlisted
video to your email
absolutely free to help you build your
confidence the link to join is in the
description below
that ended up being worse than if we
designed a car from from the beginning
to figure out where your power base is
i took my amazon lottery winnings and
built the heavy lifting infrastructure
that does take billions of dollars in
capex
to lower the cost of access to space
rule number four be clear about what you
want with jeff bezos
warren buffett has this great quote he
says you can hold a
rock concert and that's okay and you can
hold a ballet
and that's okay just don't hold a rock
concert and advertise it as a ballet
investors come in all shapes and sizes
they have
different investment horizons different
approaches different
beliefs about what the right kind of
portfolio
looks like and so it's not one you know
people
use wall street as a shorthand but there
isn't one type of investor
come in all shapes and sizes and you
have to be super clear
about what kind of company you're trying
to build what your approach is we laid
that out in our 1997 annual shareholder
letter
we said we were going to take big bets
we said they were going to fail
we said some of them hopefully we're
going to work we said we were going to
invest
for the long term that we were going to
try to take advantage of
market opportunities as they arose and
there's a certain kind of investor
who is aligned with that approach and so
again
you can hold the ballet or the rock
concert and both can work
just be clear about which one you are
and then people
can self-select rule number five serve
the customers with jack ma
and i think one of the things i want to
share with the values
the six values among the two values very
unique in alibaba which i think the
whole world should
think about we put custom number one
in priority number two shareholder
number three most
companies in wall street they put the
shareholder number one
i said each customer
is the most important if you serve them
well they pay you the money
and the second important is colleagues
why the college get together because
they want to serve the customers
if they do not cost serve the customers
why we get it together
right so if the customer happy in price
happy
the shareholders will be happy rule
number six recognize your mistakes with
warren buffett
one of the things you do in your annual
report which has become a classic
is you will discuss what went wrong
like dexter and what you and how and
and and what you learned from it tough
tough to do well it's it's it's very
important to recognize mistake i mean
if if something but it goes around and
says you know i never made a mistake i
mean
you quit listening to them i mean you
know they're in the dream world so
so facing up to it uh
it it's it's a little like in in in
terms of discussing issues
you should be able to discuss the other
fellows position just as well as you can
discuss your own so i mean that's part
of thinking well and
and certainly part of making good
decisions in business
is recognizing the poor decisions you've
made and
why they were poor and and that doesn't
mean you never do the same thing i mean
because sometimes it was a freak
situation but
but i have made lots of mistakes i'm
going to make more mistakes
uh but you know papers struck out a lot
of times i mean
it's the name of the game that you do it
you don't want to expect perfection in
yourself
you want to strive to do your best but
but it's too demanding to expect
perfection in yourself and it does some
good to recognize them and not certainly
trying to go around kidding people about
them
and rule number seven the last one
before a very special bonus clip
is don't look for the perfect job with
mark cuban
now let's pretend that you're just about
to graduate from college
right what's the advice um you don't
need the perfect job
you know um part of the problem is you
probably have a hundred thousand dollars
of debt
right um and you gotta pay off for all
that [ __ ]
um and that's really [ __ ] up it's hurt
the economy it's hard you it hurts
everybody but
um my advice general advice is assuming
there's not
just the bills you got to pay that are
just enormous
is you paid all that money to learn
now here's your chance to get paid to
learn and you don't need the perfect job
you need to get a job where you can make
some money
but also where you can learn and add it
to your portfolio of knowledge added to
your foundation because as much as we
want to think that we know
exactly what our mission in life is and
what our chosen profession is going to
be at 22
hell no there's just no chance that
the 30 year old or even the 25 year old
is going to look back at the 21 or 22
year old you
and say oh that dude had it all together
and knew exactly what was up right
he's going to look back and go beer palm
what were you thinking you know
and so it don't expect to have all the
answers and don't try to get the perfect
job
go out there and get paid to have
different experiences and it's okay to
jump from job to job if it's not the
right job
you are getting paid to learn flip it
and then use that to build your
knowledge and learn more about yourself
learn how to learn in business and see
where it can take you
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're gonna enjoy but before that
it's time for the question of the day
i want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway
from this video and what is your plan of
action that you're going to execute this
week to make some
immediate momentum happen when you just
get motivated and watch a video
you have a 35 chance of following
through that's what the science says
but when you write down what time what
day what place you're actually going to
execute when you create the plan
you have a 91 chance of following
through
and i want that for you and when you
commit to people publicly
you increase your chances even more of
actually doing it
so i want to know what your single
biggest takeaway from this video was
and your specific plan of action
to actually get the result you're after
let me know put it down in the comments
below
because i want to celebrate you
when you're down and out first thing
people do is blame it on
everybody else but themselves so true
when you start taking responsibility you
have a little different outlook
you also have the responsibility of
turning things around when i started
paul mitchell i was homeless once again
totally by accident and i started to cut
me out of the back seat of my car
how old were you at that time 30 seconds
that was 34
35 at that time so you're homeless at 34
35 again yeah
and what was this series of events that
led to that second time it was just that
we had money set up a half a million
bucks
we need to start the company with that
kind of money and uh the day i
was ready to start go down the bank and
get the money my partner the hairdresser
paul mitchell
flew her from hawaii with his girlfriend
and we were ready to get the money and
get
going and get started i'd left
everything i did
my relationship wasn't working out so
left the house plenty of money for many
months with her
had a few hundred bucks in my pocket
took the used car which is 20 years old
but a decent one okay down the hill to
get the money
wow i was going to check into an
efficiency and all set up
the money never came in no way nev the
guy changed his mind
1980 81 inflation in the united states
is 12 and a half percent
interest rates if you could get a loan
prime rate 17
wow we stayed in line to get gasoline
and
interest uh and unemployment was ten and
a half percent the united states
the guy said you're his hostages are
still in iran which they were
at that time he says is this a terrible
i'm sorry it's the last minute no
so it's a matter of what are we gonna do
if you want to change your life in the
next 30 days for free
check out my training right here below
or if you want seven more awesome
lessons from billionaires check out the
video right there next to me
i think you'll enjoy them continue to
believe and i'll see you there